[Music]
nick is with us in dallas texas hi nick
welcome to the ramsey show hi dave hey
yeah if only we could be astounding um
so i uh
i i think i already know the answer to
this um i i've read all your books and
i've i've watched the podcast and all
the things um
and i i think that that last called up
the family that was just on there was
was really awesome
honestly that's probably all i really
needed because i think i know where this
call is going to go
so here's the situation i'm a new travel
nurse
i moved all the way to dallas texas from
richmond
and i ended up getting into a wreck
i got this 2000 toyota 4runner
and it's been my baby it's made it to
250 000 miles and
it's it's pretty much time to say
goodbye i got it appraised
at 8 000
on the first appraisal and then the
second was
uh two and a half but that guy that guy
hasn't called me back and he's kind of
from a sketchy area
so
um i think what i'm looking at here is
getting uh getting a beater
but i'm a little nervous because if i
did
i don't know if it'd be so safe on the
highways when i when i go to my next
place
and um
my friend he used to be a car salesman
and he's been he's been trying to tell
me that
it might just make more sense to to go
ahead and get a car loan and
get something new because of the
inflation wait a minute a car salesman
told you this
this is a credible piece of information
yeah
all right
okay wait a minute dude have you gained
money
not no all right we've we've been best
friends literally since middle school i
mean um he's not trying to no no not him
he's out of the picture he's already
discredited himself
he doesn't even work he's not he no
longer gets a vote because his opinion
is dumb now let's move on do you have
any money
nah man i mean no money at all okay you
don't have any money in savings at all
i've got four hundred dollars okay i've
got the car did you total the forerunner
oh man it's uh i mean it's running did
you have did you have insurance
uh i've got liability oh you didn't have
collision
okay so you just lost your car
it's going to sell broken for help for
eight grand
broken it'll i mean
so 8k was to was to
fix it oh fix it oh you're saying you
get quotes okay got it you don't have
eight grand though
no definitely not and you don't have
insurance to fix it so yeah before you
spend eight grand to fix this piece of
crap you'd spend eight grand to buy a
car but in either case you don't have
eight grand so let's start again
uh you have four hundred dollars to your
name
i've got a credit card man but yeah i
know how you feel about where where's
your money going you said you're a
travel nurse that's good money
yeah so the way i mean it sounds real
real great you know but there's honestly
there's a period where you've you've got
to make ends meet before your first like
your first pain like you get money from
from the uh agency
so
um
anyway i've made
two i've gotten two paychecks so far and
um
after
paying back all the travel expenses and
and um
the the credit card i ended up getting
um is the car paid off now do you have a
zero balance on it
uh-huh yep
and it will sell in its current
condition for how much
800 that's what carmax told me right so
you can get you got a thousand dollars
to your name when do you get your next
check
yes
when do you get your next check
uh this is coming friday how much will
it be
2800
okay
um
all right i can only tell you what i
would do in your situation
you painted yourself into a really
difficult corner because you've saved
absolutely no money and you didn't carry
collision insurance which you should
have been doing both of those things
okay
so today we're gonna start listening to
dave and george and start doing this
stuff so your next goal is to get a
thousand dollars in the bank after we
get you a car
okay but if i woke up in your shoes your
back is against the wall i'd sell the
car for 800 i'd take a thousand of my
1200 i'd take a thousand out of the
check that's coming friday and i'd buy a
two thousand dollar car
i would drive that for two to three
months
meanwhile i'm gonna save like a crazy
man and buy an eight thousand dollar car
and i want you to work like a freaking
maniac like every hour they will give
you
and i want you to quit partying
i lived it up a little bit on the way
here
there it is that's what i was waiting
for a little bit of honesty out of nick
yeah dave's exactly right uh the whole
idea that if you buy a beater car it's
gonna explode on the interstate that's
just a load of baloney and it's
justification my car i'm driving right
now cost me six thousand dollars and
i've been driving it for almost five
years
and it's a beater but it runs it's a
honda so go get you ever left you out
no never left you stranded never not one
time
so okay look for a good used car that's
reasonable right now and that's not
gonna be sweet for two grand
two thousand it's ugly but reliable i
wanted here's the thing nick your
situation is
you're you're painted in this corner
because you you're
you're living for the moment your entire
whole calendar and your checkbook is
yolo
it's every bit thank god it's friday oh
god it's monday and i want you to flip
that and start having a vision for your
life a decade from now the kind of man
you want to be
the kind of place you want to be
how you want to be living and the amount
of wealth you want to build
because if if you keep living like
you're living you're going to keep
having the same problems you got
i noticed that when i was completely
broke that my life looked like a country
song
everything that can go wrong well keep
the dog out of the street it'll get hit
oh my god everything that can go wrong
well right
and that's what's happening to you and
it's because you've lived down to the
nub on everything
i mean you've left yourself no margin in
your schedule
and um you're living for the moment and
i it's nothing
i'm not shaming you i'm just telling you
how to fix this young man
and so uh
throw your shoulders back and let's say
i need a five year a ten year vision for
my life
and what are the steps for me to get
there and you can have enjoyment along
that journey as well
but in seeking enjoyment all the time
all you found is stress
yeah i mean there's a lot of that yellow
mentality happening here and like dave
said if you get that vision i mean sign
up for our building wealth live stream
and start to picture what would it be
like
five years from now 10 years from now
fully funded emergency fund maybe i'm
starting a family i've got money in the
bank i'm hitting my goals and i use this
moment as a never again moment where you
said never again am i gonna not have the
right insurance have four hundred
dollars to my name and have nothing to
show for my money we had a lady that
when covet hit she moved to travel
nursing and she had 350 000 student loan
debt in 12 months she made 500 000
as a travel nurse working 80 hours a
week every coveted thing she could get
on
and yeah there's some risk to that i i
am not a medical professional i'm just
admiring that she had a vision for her
life and went from deep in a hole and a
mess to 500 000 12 months later now she
quit
after that and went back and you can't
do that forever you should burn the
candle at both ends but for 12 months
she laid it on the line because she had
a vision for her life and said i'm never
going to be in this situation again
and um
and so maybe this car wreck uh wakes you
up
and maybe this is your your time that
you say never again
or maybe you keep living like you've
been living and you're gonna keep
getting what you've been getting my
brother
it's a reaping and sowing thing when you
plant corn don't be shocked corn grows
that's how this life works
you're a good man nick thank you for
calling in we're honored to talk to you